there's new rocket League DLC for $4 you
can purchase revenge of the battle cars
what's in it
Wow read the question let's take a look
kicking off you get two new whips scarab
and zippy make an appearance from the
first game
supersonic acrobatic rocket powered
battle cars scarab looks like a buggy
Mars rover and zippy looks well well he
looks iffy each of the new cars comes
with six decals couple of them familiar
a couple of them unique scarab for
example comes with bomani and tribal and
zippy brings you Calais and leopard Riau
pick up your fav and get wacky with the
new paint type tune choose between
glossy matte and wood and bring a little
cel-shaded life to your car once you got
that paint job down you be sure to strap
on one of the two new wheel types scarab
and zippy and you keep moving right on
over to the new rocket trails
Battlestars brings a magical streak to
your trail
but where the parties really at is with
Excel urato which adds not only a line
of musical notes to your boost trail but
a [ __ ] in power chord making your
aerials bad ass
this DLC brings four fantastic Stoppers
beat a Cavalier and let that feather fly
in the wind next off the locomotives
deal with these pixelated shades and
then the real winner shark fin and so
good other than that you got some free
editions with the update including retro
ball antennas community and video game
flags and two new arenas here's the
vibrant and colorful utopia Coliseum at
dusk and this is urban central at night
well that's it for me let me leave you
with this slam dunk oh my god stay tuned
next week for the DeLorean car pack from
Back to the Future fun stuff you take
care now